in this lesson we're going to talk about
the important chemistry of the coenzyme
coenzyme a which is shown here you might
not have realized coenzyme a is so large
of a molecule because we often
abbreviate it like this it looks a lot
smaller when it's written out as these
five letters so here we're abbreviating
everything from here on as this co a and
we just show the HS because that's
really where the important chemistry
happens with this molecule linking up
with other molecules but coenzyme a is
actually made up of this system een
bonded in an amide linkage to beta
alanine linked up in another a m''d to
panto ik acid then to a diphosphate and
finally to this three phospho adenosine
piece over here
when coenzyme a covalently bonds to a
molecule via this sulfur it makes a thio
ester bond so we need to discuss why
thio esters are important in
biochemistry so here's our coenzyme a
ester this sulfur adjacent to a carbonyl
is the thio ester and we can get it why
this is important if we compare it to a
carboxylic acid so if this molecule
underwent hydrolysis and a molecule of
water cleaved right here at the carbonyl
we would get acetic acid so here's the
structure of acetic acid now if we put
this into the environment of the body
assuming this is at blood pH which is
seven point for this molecule becomes
ionized acetic acid has a pKa of 4.6 so
at pH 7.4 we're we're above the pKa more
basic than the pKa of this molecule it
loses a proton and becomes this anion
now say for example we wanted this
carboxylate the ionized carboxylic acid
to react with a nucleophile
well that's gonna be pretty tough now
our nucleophile may have a formal
negative charge as I've shown here but
regardless it's going to have lone pairs
of electrons which are negative and it's
going to want to attack here and push
these electrons up well that's putting a
whole lot of negative charge on this
molecule we have repulsion already
because these two negative things don't
want to come together so at the pH of
the blood it's quite difficult for a
negative to react with the negative
carboxylate but here in this thio ester
we don't have this buildup of negative
charge and we have sulphur a good
leaving group so if we treat our
coenzyme a ester with a nucleophile
we'll get displacement of the ESCO a
group there are three hydrogen atoms
here adjacent to this carbonyl because
of the dipole here and the resonance of
the carbonyl these hydrogen atoms are
somewhat acidic so if we treat this with
a base which I'm representing with a
negative charge here to show some
electrons that can attack we can get
deprotonation of one of these hydrogen
atoms forming an enolate the enolate can
be drawn like this or we can show its
resonance form with the negative charge
on oxygen as you might imagine this
reaction to be deprotonated is also
difficult for the ionized carboxylate
we're trying to put an anion on carbon
when this molecule already has a lot of
negative charge so the thio ester allows
nucleophilic attack at the carbonyl and
makes enolization occur more readily now
let's look at two examples of coenzyme a
esters in biochemistry so we can see
these processes Illustrated so
analyzation and nucleophilic attack in
the TCA cycle acetyl coenzyme a which
I'm showing with one of these acidic
protons drawn out is going to bind to an
enzyme I'm
representing the binding pocket of this
enzyme citrate synthase as this pink
line here the enzyme also binds
oxaloacetate the side chains of amino
acids in the active site are going to
deprotonate here analyzing this part of
the molecule this is going to attack
this carbonyl so I'm going to set up my
active site with a few generic amino
acid side chains in it here we have a
proton acceptor and here we have a
proton donor which the enzyme
strategically places near the two
substrates this basic residue is going
to remove this proton the electrons that
would be left behind to form the enolate
can attack now so I'm showing this
deprotonation and I'm simultaneously
going to show the enol II attacking the
carbonyl the double bond to the oxygen
will open up accepting a proton from
this proton donor this will give us an
intermediate now citrate the final
product of this reaction actually has an
O H group here so we can show this as an
enzyme promoted process where a molecule
of water binds and an enzyme residue
that's acting as a proton acceptor can
deprotonate one of the hydrogen atoms on
this water molecule allowing these
electrons to attack displacing ESCO a
and i'm going to add in a proton donor
amino acid side chain so that coenzyme a
can leave in its protonated form
hydrolysis gives us our molecule of
citrate which can be released from the
enzyme this carboxylate here corresponds
to this s co a ester that we hydrolyzed
in the previous step coenzyme a esters
are super important and fatty acid
biosynthesis as well in fatty acid
synthesis acetyl coenzyme a and this
molecule Milanoo coenzyme a will be
transferred to the
so carrier protein so here the coenzyme
a esters are allowing for a reaction
called transesterification and we're
swapping for another sulfur group at
this carbonyl when we attach it to the
enzyme the interesting thing about this
is the enzyme bound sulfur donor is
super similar to coenzyme a itself this
sulfur containing group is a phospho
Pantha thene so our phospho pantothenic
extends all the way over to this
phosphate group so incredibly similar to
coenzyme a itself now the enzyme bound
Milanoo coenzyme a undergoes a
decarboxylation which is going to form
an enolate here now I could show my
electrons coming up and making an anion
on this carbon but I'm going to use an
even more abbreviated shorthand so we're
breaking this bond this is going to come
off as co2 these electrons that are left
behind are going to attack at our enzyme
bound acetyl coenzyme a piece of course
this will form a tetrahedral
intermediate that will push the
electrons back down and kick off the
protein but we can just show one arrow
abbreviating that whole process let's
draw what we get so the piece that
originated from acetyl coenzyme a has
gotten kicked off of the protein and is
now bound to the Milanoo coenzyme a
piece that remains enzyme bound this is
the first part of a multi-step process
we're going to eventually lose this
carbonyl and extend the chain again and
again until a fatty acid of the proper
length for that enzyme is produced to
sum up coenzyme a esters are very
important in biochemistry because they
undergo reactions that are quite
difficult for carboxylates in the body
at blood pH of 7.4 these reactions are
nucleophilic attack and enol ization of
these alpha hydrogen's both the TCA
cycle and
acid biosynthesis provide examples where
we see the enol ization of coenzyme a
esters and also we see how easily they
can undergo nucleophilic attack and
displacement